dear
evan hansen today is going to be an
amazing day
and here's why
[Music]
have you been doing those letters to
yourself with dr sherman i've been
trying to
have you ever felt like nobody was there
um no one's on your cast
now we can both pretend we are friends
i'm sorry about my brother
have you ever felt forgotten in the
middle of nowhere i wish everything was
different
wish i was part of something i wish that
anything i said
mattered have you ever felt like you
could disappear
dear evan hansen yeah yeah that's mine
i'll i'll just take it wait i really i
need that back
he could fall and no one
would hear connor took a letter from me
and it was an assignment for my
therapist too
even when the dark comes crashing
through connor's mother and stepfather
here to see you
when you need a friend to carry you
connor wanted you to have this and when
you're broken on the ground
dear evan hansen he wrote it to you his
last awards
conor took his own life hey what
i'm sorry connor didn't write this no no
no please
what's this you will be fine
we didn't think connor had any friends
i mean you really going to tell these
people that the only thing they have
left of their son
was a letter that you wrote to yourself
so you and connor tell us something
please
right um i started talking and you
couldn't stop they didn't want me to
stop
i'm putting together a memorial service
if you wanted to do something
connor showed me that i wasn't alone
nobody is so let that lonely feeling
wash away
maybe there's a reason to believe you'll
be okay i didn't know that you were hurt
because when you don't feel
strong enough to stand a lot of people
feel like us
you can't reach reach out
your head
people started sharing it it's
everywhere
i don't understand what happened you did
you don't know how much you've given my
family
were you ever actually friends with him
i never meant to make it such a mess i
was
trying to help
if you knew who i am just
how broken i am i already know you
and i love you
i have to tell them
[Music]
you